体に良いもの悪いもの
無能な肉体を主座から降格
本来の支配者に支配者は心ですと
今までの人間が肉体を主座に置いていたんですよ
冗談じゃないんで ただの物体なのに
肉体のために生きてるんで
それを降ろしてほしいんです
心が肉体を生かしてるんです
だから心はもう逆にしないと
それで理性と適 適度 これ体のこと
体に対して理性と適度っていうのを守って維持しなくちゃいけない
健康食品 栄養補助食品ばかり食べていても
期待するほど健康な肉体にはなりません
我々期待しても期待してもそうはなりませんよ
例えば黒人は白人食べる食べ物ばっかり一生選んで食べても白人にはなりませんね
変えませんよ どれぐらい若くなったら良いか
どれぐらい美しくなったら良いか
どれぐらい強くなったら良いかは
人に上限はありませんね
ただ若くなりたい 美しくなりたいと思うだけであって
上限がないんですね 心の欲に上限はないからです
なぜならば 心知る機能の欲には上限がないんです
いくらでも成り立ちます
だから我々の欲にも上限がないんです
期待にも 上限のない欲の衝動で物質を変えようとしても
物質は自然法則の中で変化するんです
だから限りない欲でもうあれもします
これもします 言ってもありえませんよ
もう分かりやすい例で
この望みは一番早い新幹線ですけど
もっと早い 500 キロで走れる
なんとかリニアモーターカーなんかね
開発しようとしていますよ
あれってまず欲なんですね
もっとスピード出したいと
しかし もう 20年も研究しています
まだまだ 電車はできてますよ
でも実験 あれだけで走ってるだけで
普通の人々に使えるようにとはもうかなり遠い話なんですね
ということは 欲があるだけではうまく機能しない
あらゆる自然法則の中で変化させなくちゃいけないんですよ
で アメリカだったらね
まあ月の月を開拓するんだそうとか
もう話だけはあるんだけど
開拓した覚えはないんです
そんな夢の話を行っただけではうまくいくわけじゃないんです
で 日常生活の中で我々はこの上限のない欲で生きてるんですけど
それはうまくいかないんですよ
法則があるんだからね
それは理解してないんだから
みんな精神的に落ち込んじゃうんです
思う通りにならないんです
欲があっても 法則は変えられませんから
だから人間というのは危ないんですよ
この上限のない 限りのない欲の衝動で生きてますよ
だから 生きる上で何したっても
結局は失敗で危険な結果で終わる
だから 何のことなく戦争になってくると
みんな戦争する  50年前で
日本の兵隊さんは平気で化学物質を作ったりして
人体人体実験までしていたんです
中国人も捕まってはいろんなウイルスをいろんなものを体につけて病気にさせて観察したりする
ものすごい恐ろしいことをやっている
全然それはもう関係ないんですね
今そんなことはないことにして
そんなないことにしたってないことになりませんだからね
だから人間というのは
このもう上限のない欲
無限の欲を持ってるんだから
もうやることっていうのは本当にもう危ない
最終的にはすごい不幸な結果になる
どんなものでもそうなっちゃいますよ
ライフドア ライフドアにしてももう同じことで
もう欲に上限がなくなったんだから
もう全部潰れてしまって
もう大変悲しい結果になったりする
肉体では変えられる 変えられるところも変えられないところもある
この体で変えられるところもありますし
変えられないところもあります
もう変えられるところというのはほんのわずかですけどね
例えば自分好きなように身長を伸ばすっていうことはできない
やっても子供の頃はね
いろんな薬飲ませてやらせてもいいんだけど
ホルモン剤やらね でもかえって危ないんですよ
まあ成長ホルモンっていろいろありますけど
例えば体伸びるために必要なホルモン注射すれば伸びますよ
危ない あの スポーツの世界で何かみんな薬なんか使ってそれ禁止されてますね
あれ 何薬っていうんですかね
筋肉うん 筋肉なんとか何とかとかね
ありましてね で まあ女性のね
スポーツの人々とかね
またそういういろいろホルモン剤を打ったりして
体が男性になり変わっちゃうんですね
結局 それでスポーツというのは一生やるものじゃないんだからね
もうすぐやめなくちゃいけないし
それからもうどんどんおかしくなったりするし
まあかえって良くないんです
とにかく良くない しかしただ持ってる体で
毎日もう 10 キロぐらいか 5 キロぐらいはジョギングをするとかね
それで体力を保せるとかね
まあそれぐらいは変えられます
それではもう一生健康ではいられます
で 髪の毛をね もう脱色させて金髪にしたんだからといって
決してアメリカ人にはなりませんよ
よくやってますけどね
みんな だから まあ思うほど変えられませんだけど
変えられる範囲があって
そこを理解しておけば上限が成り立つのですよ
それを理解すると上限が見えてくる
何を食べれば良いか 何を食べてはいけないのかは仏教は語りません
もう体としてはもう食べるものと運動すること 2つだけですからね
仏教はあんまり言わない
そんなことは何を食べればいいかないかとかね
それは肉体の研究する専門家の仕事ですからね
一生懸命肉体のことを研究している人々いるんだから
その人々に任せてくださいと
お釈迦様は病気になったらお医者さんに頼む頼んだんだからね
それはもう医者の仕事
あんたやりなさいと まあ一回怪我したことがありまして
それで怪我の手当てはもうある医者がしてあげたんです
まあ治療を受けたものはそれ 1箇所だけ
1箇所だけですけど 体が病気になって倒れたことは何回もありましたけど
その場合はじーっと治るまで待っていたんです
何回 何回もすごい激しい下痢になったりね
赤痢になったりはしました
2  3回ぐらいは  その場合はもうまあ消化機能の問題でしたから
また何かね 悪いウイルスとか入ったでしょうと思いますよね
その場合はじーっと治るまで待っていて
ということで あまりまあ病気は医者の仕事で
何食べればいいかということは栄養士の仕事で
まあそれまでは言わない
はい しかし 生命には食べ物に対する本能というものもある
本能が決める食べ物は体に適したものなのです
これ覚えたらどうですかね
皆様にも食べ物に対する本能があるはずなんです
例えば 動物は本能で食べてるんですよ
だから自然の中で生きている動物は食べ過ぎになったっていうことはないでしょうし
高血圧になったっていうことはないでしょうね
面白いでしょ 人間飼ってる犬には全部人間の病気がうつるでしょ
高血圧やら白内障やら
心臓が弱くなることやら
全部あります デブ猫っていうのは人間飼って飼ってる時だけでしょうに
野良猫はデブになりませんよ
そこでいっぱい餌があるところで
でも生きてる生命っていうのは太ってないんですよ
面白くないんですかね
それが 餌がありすぎて太ってるということはないんです
しかし 動物園の動物はみんな太ってます
日本の動物園 すごいストレスかかってると思います
食べ過ぎ 私はいろいろ動物園に行ったことありますけど
行ったらなんかおかしいなと
不自然だなと これみんな太ってるんだ
人間の手に入っちゃうとそんなことになります
しかし 食べ物はいっぱいありあふれている環境でいる動物でも太ったりはしない
それってどうやって管理するんですかね？本能ですよ
これが生き物だから 人間にもあるはずなんです
それは知識で壊れちゃったんです
これはあの知る機能よりも激しいんです
知識は 本能で食べるということはどういうことかというと
本能で見ると 何かある食べ物を見ると無性においしく見えるんですね
匂いはもうなんか誘惑されるわ
形は誘惑するわ それでそれ取って食べると
何かと分からなくても取って食べるとすごく楽しくなっちゃって
それで自然にもういいやということになっちゃうんです
それ 知識が入るともっと食べたいということになります
それで本能で食べると
適量で食べたらあの本能がなくなっちゃうんです
で ストップになるんです
例えば 1 日 2 3000カロリーか何とか取らなくちゃいけないと知識で思っちゃうと
それは測ってみて食べちゃう
それは本能ではまるっきりないんです
自分の肉体に聞けば 栄養は必要かないかと
肉体が栄養必要だったら信号を出すんですよ
例えば栄養 いろんな例えばビタミンがもう欠けたり
いろんなミネラルが欠けたりしちゃうと
自動的に体のこのなんていうのは食欲じゃなくて
なんか自動的に別なものを食べたくなるんですよ
まあ何なんでしょうかね
まあ人間にはあの居座り
薄回りでしたっけ？練習するときに出てる状況は
座り  座り あれがみんな不自然だと思ってますね
では不自然ではなくて
普段食べているものは嫌になったりして
なんか別なものはやけに食べたくなったりとかね
やっぱりその場合は本能が機能するんですよ
それが本能なんですね
だからそこで肉体のバランスを肉体が考えて
この崩れ バランス崩れてるものは
これ入れなさいよと言ってるんです
だから普段と違って なんか変なものを食べてるんですね
変なものではなくて なんか別なものはわさわさといっぱい食べたりするんですね
そういう時 体要求するものをあげると
あのバランスちゃんと整えてきて
ある時期でそれも消えちゃって
普通に食べるようになるんです
大体人間の場合は 女性だけ妊娠している時だけは
まあ本能が結構機能するんです
その時は本人も知りません
いつ食べるか 何食べるか
どれぐらい食べるかと全然気にしない
それぐらい自分のお腹の状態が変で
それで大変頭がそちらに行ってるんです
だから食べるものの場合は
また本能が再び働き出すんです
それで面白いことにいって勉強するんですね
妊娠中どうすればいいか
何を食べればいいか どれぐらい何を栄養を取ればいいかって
これは最悪です それからまあ栄養補助品やらあれやこれや入れたりして
生まれた子供はまたヒステリーで
神経質で アトピーで 不自然になるんです
何にも勉強しないんだったらうまくいくんです
何も知らないんだったらお産さえもできますよ
一人で この本能っていうのは面白いんですよ
だから知識っていうのはすごく良くないんですよ
だからこの人間でも もし本能で食べることにするならば
このもう健康志向っていうのはもう全然やらなくなっちゃうよ
あんなのは知識世界だからね
それでこの前タイトルだけ書いておいたんですけど
理性と適度ということは考えてくださいと
次に この汚染した健康食品
は何でしょうかね 一応リストは書きません
なぜならば いろいろ問題を受けますからね
怒り 欲 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み
傲慢 見栄などの感情で世界一良い食べ物を食べても
体の中で毒に変わるんです
汚染するんです 食べ物に罪がないんです
食べる時の気持ち 慈しみ
理性 落ち着きの心で 正しく栄養が整えてないものを食べても
体が健康的に維持されます
あまり健康やら栄養っていうのをもう整えてなくても
心だけ穏やかで慈しみがあったら
もう体知ってます あ これでこれでこれでこれでこうあります
それで答えは食べ物よりは食べる気持ちに注意
体に良いものといえば
たった秒で終わるんです
食べるものよりは食べる気持ちに注意しなさいと
食べ物に対する理性 体は物質よりとても早く壊れますよ
我々の体はこのマイクロスタンドより早く壊れます
これ 生き 生き続けたい心はそれを修復しようとする
体っていうのは もうもうほんとみるみるうちに壊れるんですよ
疲れますよ ちょっと 30 分ぐらいでも一箇所で座っていれば
それ食われた 壊れたっていうことなんですよ
ちょっと 30 分立っていただけで
もう疲れるんですよ もうできなくなっちゃうんで
壊れるんです ずーっとすごい早く壊れる
それで我々は生き続けたいでしょ？死にたくないんでしょ？だから壊れるたびに修復するんです
これは食べるっていうことなんです
だから肉体は 24時間休憩なし
栄養を取っています 我々は口で食べるのは 1 日 3回かもしれませんだけど
体はずっと 1 秒たりとも休むことなく栄養を取っています
それぐらい早く体が壊れているんです
壊れていく体に修復するために必要な材料を与えると理解することは理性です
すごくつまらないんだけど
これ科学的な事実なんです
美しく食文化じゃないんです
そんなのは危ないんです
科学には文化がありません
もう淡々たる事実だけ
だから食べるってことはどういうことかというと
壊れる体に修復するために必要な材料部品を与える
それだけ それを覚えておけば
これ理性なんです 食文化という単語が入ると
もう終わり 毒になります
食べるものは しかし 汚れた心は取った食べ物は毒になるので
清らかなんですね 清らかな心で摂取するんです
もしここ汚れていると
材料だけあげましょうと思ったってのは毒になるんです
だからいつでも綺麗な心で
明るい心で 優しい心で食べなくちゃいけないんです
何食べてもいいんで 食べたものは毒になります
ですから 心は基準ですね
で 心は基準ということに別
ちょっと別の話します
あの 経典からいろんな仏典からね
引用しようと思えば山ほどありますけど
全部はもう使いません
時間ないんですからね
殺し屋と医者に接待したとしましょう
2人を自分の家に招待して
ごちそうをあげて食べさせる
2人が来るんで 一人が殺し屋プロの
もう一人は医者なんです
殺し屋が元気になって人を殺しに行くんです
美味しいものを食べて元気になっちゃって
では仕事に行こうと言って人殺しに行くんです
医者は元気になって病院を直すんです
だから同じ食べ物は結果 2つ出したでしょ
それ 誰が決めたんですかね？食べ物何でも問題なかったでしょ
でも 食べた心が次の結果を決めちゃうんです
それジャータカ物語にも結構ありますよ
食べ物とそれを食べる生命の性格の関係を示すジャータカ物語もあります
ジャータカ物語ぐらいは皆様自分で勉強できますので
読んでみてください 一つは面白いことをちょっと思い出した
ジャータカの一部だけ言いますけど
ある王様があの自分の国で
何か反対するね  グループがいて
その人々を抑えるために戦争に行ったんです
自分で行かなかったので軍隊を送ったんです
それで馬 軍隊と歩兵やらみんなで言って戦ったんです
その地方の問題を戦って勝って帰ったんです
だから王様が馬たちはよく頑張ってくれたんだと
戦闘でもビシビシと仕事をして敵を倒してくれた
ご褒美あげなくちゃ それ
軍隊と一緒にロバ隊も行くんですよ
ロバっていうのはすごい足が弱いです
まあ遅いでしょ もう戦争には役に役に立ちませんが
物質を運ぶんですよ 食べ物やら武器やらね
ロバの背中に乗って運ぶで
馬は何も持ってない ただ
あの馬の背中に乗っている騎士だけで戦争に行くんですけど
で 馬食べる食べ物はロバが運んであげないと
それで軍隊が戦争に勝って
一箇所で止まったところで
まあ馬が馬のところでちゃんとつけておいて
ロバたちが別なところに
それで王様が馬たちがよく頑張ってくれたんだからと言って
ご褒美あげなくちゃと言って
あのブドウ 大量にブドウを持ってきて
全部潰して あのジュースを飲ませたんです
それは 1 日でやったことじゃないと思いますけど
まあかなり前から用意していたものやと思います
だから一応酒は入ってるんです
発酵するんだから だから粕なんか全部取って
純粋なこのジュースだけ
まあワインだと思ってください
馬たちはそれいっぱい飲んで
何のことなく音も立てないでじーっといるんです
それで兵隊さんが王様にこの粕はいっぱいあるんだけど
これどうしましょうかと
ああ しょうがない ロバたちも頑張ったんだから
この粕をね ロバたちに食べさせなさい
粕にしても これブドウの粕だからね
普段食べるものよりは結構美味しいんですけど
それでロバたちはいっぱいこれ食べちゃって
もう叫ぶは暴れまわるはすごいうるさかったんだ
もう兵隊さんが疲れてるの
一人も寝ることができなかった
酔っ払っちゃって 暴れ回っちゃって大変なことになったと
それを見たこの菩薩がね
で 王様がどういうことかと
これはと言ったら まあこれは食べ物じゃなくて性格だよ
お父様 王様に教えてあげたんです
性格のいい馬は もっと高級な食べ物を食べたのに落ち着いているんだと
性格の悪いロバたちが粕食べてるのに
あんな調子やと だから面白いこと
現代人は食べ物で全部決めると思ってるでしょうね
本当はあれがもう完全に間違い
逆なんです 性格で食べる食べ物が毒か決めるんですよ
おにぎり 1個手で持って
このおにぎりが本当に健康にいい
体にいい食べ物か 体の健康を壊す毒になろうかっていうことは
自分の心が決めるんです
おにぎり おにぎりは単なるおにぎりで
それが本当の事実です
世界 そういう世界なんです
解脱を目指す人が持つべき食べ物
食べ物に対するアプローチを
我が子の肉を食べて死を免れる例えで説明してあります
これは皆様に今日は関係ない話なんですけど
仏教っていうのは解脱をしなさいと瞑想して悟りなさいという話なんです
それで在家の人々は出家するんですよ
解脱したくて 悟り開きたくて
開きたくて 出家しても食べ物に依存しちゃうと
もう欲だけで欲を足すことはできないんですね
それで 食べ物に対する体に対する理性と適度を理解してほしいんです
いきなり一発で時間ないんです
うろうろうろうろするためには
だから一発で教えてあげるんです
これが適度と理性やと食べ物に対するたとえ話です
これもジャータカにもあります
ある夫婦は子供もいて
3人で旅に出る 旅に出ると砂漠に入ることになるんです
砂砂漠で もう木は 1本もなく
水もなくで そこで苦しんで苦しんで
この砂漠でも行くわ行くわ
行くわ行くわ まあ水はないし
食べ物はないし それでどうなるのかというと
死ぬでしょ 誰が先に死ぬんですかね
子供は先に死ぬんですよね
子供はまあすぐ食べ物必要ですから
子供の体にはね 簡単に脱水症状を起こせますよ
子供死んじゃうんですよ
このお父さんとお母さんがもう悲しくてたまらない
でも次に自分も死にます
もう砂漠はもっと遠いオアシスまでは
体は持たない そこまでは
それでこの夫婦は考えるんです
我々には食べ物はない
では この肉を食べましょう
食べ物もあるんじゃないか
自分の子供の死体なんですよ
それで この自分の子供の死んだ自分の子供の肉を食べるんです
食べて体力は取り戻して
もう砂漠を歩むんです
またお腹が空いたら また残ってるんだから
肉をね それ食べてまた歩む
その間でも子供のこと泣くんです
なんでかわいそうに死んだんでしょうかと
いかに自分が子供を愛していたんでしょうかと
かわいくてかわいくてたまらなかったと泣きながら子供の肉を食べるんです
それでその夫婦はとにかく砂砂漠を脱出する
そのたとえ それで比丘は
あの夫婦は自分の子供の肉を食べたような気分でご飯食べなさい
これで美味しい 美味しいところじゃないでしょうに
もうものすごい もう食べられないでしょうに
ひとかけらも執着生まれないでしょうに
ただ単にもう食べなきゃ自分の命も終わるっていうことだから
だから砂砂漠は輪廻のことで
とにかく輪廻を超えなくちゃいけないんですよ
輪廻を超えるまでは生き続けなくちゃいけないので
そのために食べ物は取るんだけど
食べ物っていうのは自分の死んだ子供の死体を食べてるんだと
そのたとえ話 一発でわかるでしょ
食べ物に対するアプローチは
だからお釈迦様 出家した人々にはそんな時間かかずに
すごい一言葉で教えてあげる
これが道やと だから興味半分で出家したっても
あんまりダメですよ 覚悟を決めないとかなり厳しいんです
言うこととかね しかし
そのたとえ話ではすごくコンパクトで
出家は食べ物にどんな態度をとるべきかというのに
ただ死ぬんだから食べるんであって
そんなに生き続けたいのかというと
そうじゃない ちょこっと生きていれば瞑想して覚えられるんだと
ただそのためやと 生きる目的と食べ物
これからまた普通の世界に戻ります
生きるために食べる 食べるために生きる
生きるから食べる どちらをとっています？皆様どちらでしょうかね
3選択以外はないよ 一応世の中にはその 3 選択というか出てこない
生きるために食べるか
食べるために生きるか
生きるから食べるか 聞かない
答えはどちらでも矛盾で無意味です
生きるために食べるにしても
どうせ死ぬんだから意味がないでしょうに
食べても食べてももう死ぬんだから
食べればどんどん年取って死ぬでしょうに
食べるために生きると言ったら
なんで情けないんでしょうかね
生きるから食べるにしても
でも結局は死ぬんだからね
だからどちらでも矛盾で意味がないんです
心を完全に清らかにする
解脱をする 涅槃を体験すると決めたら
食べることに意味が生じます
食べることにその時だけ意味が生じるんですよ
だから即席の食べることには何の意味もないんです
ただ食べるために生きるぐらいの生き方なんです
しかし 仏教の世界では
心にはもう命には目的があるんだと
心を完全に綺麗にするんだと
貪瞋痴を完全に貪瞋痴を完全に取り除くんだと
解脱をするんだと 輪廻を脱出するんだと
悟ってやるんだという目的を作るんです
そうすると その目的に達するまでは生きていないと
それで初めて食べることに意味が生じるんです
人生そのものには何の意味もないんです
だから食べることにも何の意味もないんです
意味が作らなくちゃいけないです
目的を その人は執着を足すために新たな執着を作らないで
ただ体を維持する目的で食べるんです
その人はもう美味しいんだから食べてるんじゃなくて
まあこれでちょこっと命がつなげてくれると
それでその延ばしてもらった時間で修行するんだということで食べているんだから
執着は生まれてこない
体に悪い食べ物 食べ物なら体に悪いはずはありませんよ
それはおかしい よくみんな体に悪い食べ物はあまり悪い食べ物を食べないでくださいとおかしいんです
それが 食べ物でしょう
例えば人間はね あの あなた床に食べないでください
これ体に悪いやと そんな話には誰も食べてないんだからね
それで糖尿病の人には甘いものを
高血圧の人には脂肪が
含んだ食べ物などは食べ物ではありません
だから初めからもう頭がおかしい
ただ 私がすごい糖尿病だったら
もうすごい甘いものをいっぱい食べることは良くない
それは私にとって食べ物ではありません
これは食べ物と思ったところで間違いなんです
糖尿病なのに これこれ食べ物やと
ソフトケーキは食べ物や
ソフトケーキっていいんですかね
うん 思ったところで間違いなんです
糖尿病の人がもういっぱい
もういろんなものを入れちゃって
チョコレートやらクリームやら
ものすごく長く住み重ねたものいたら
すごい毒やと こんなのはもう食べ物じゃないと思わないと
ああ 気持ち悪いと見ただけでも
ああ どうしようか おいしい
私は好物なのにとかね
でもまあしょうがない
後で薬飲みますから で
食べたりするでしょ 頭が悪いだけな
食べ物でないものは食べ物だと勘違いする
それだけのこと だから世界で言うべきなのは
お医者さんも言うべきなのは
栄養士も言うべきなのは
あなたの食べ物はこれこれであって
これは食べ物じゃないんだよと
それで混乱できてると
その問題がないんですよ
体に悪いものを見たら気持ち悪くなるんです
自然もういいやと そんなのは臭いんだと
味 香りも臭くするんですよ
汚れた心が食べ物を汚染するだけです
なんでこんな問題になるかでもあってよ
ただ 体に悪い食べ物はないんです
我々の心が食べ物を汚染するんです
次のポイント 頭に良いもの